once again Mark Ronson and Miley Cyrus
Pete Davidson briefly appears on
Saturday Night Live after posting a
troubling message on Instagram earlier
that day Pete deleted his Instagram
after writing a concerning post that
read I really don't want to be on this
earth anymore I'm doing my best to stay
here for you but I actually don't know
how much longer I can last all I've ever
tried to do was help people just
remember I told you so now this is a
scary few hours for fans and Friends
police confirmed to The Hollywood
Reporter that they did perform a
wellness check on the comic after the
post and later found he was safe celebs
like Nicki Minaj Jon Cryer and Machine
Gun Kelly shared messages of support
Machine Gun Kelly tweeted that he was
actually on a plane on his way to see
Pete and make sure he's good
and Pete's ex Ariana Grande since
deleted her tweet but she shared man I'm
so sorry I told a dumb joke I really
didn't mean any harm all I want everyone
to be healthy and happy so desperately
please my god and this is seemingly in
response to her tweet about Kanye West's
Twitter rant against Drake in which
Kanye discussed mental health issues her
next tweet seemed directed right at Pete
and said I'm downstairs and I'm not
going anywhere if you need anyone or
anything I know you have everyone you
need and that's not me but I'm here -
yes and Pete has been so candid about
his mental health struggles and has used
SNL as a platform he goes on Weekend
Update pretty frequently to talk about
it I was recently diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder a form
of depression and depression affects
more than like 16 million people in this
country and there's no like cure per se
but for anyone dealing with it there are
treatments that can help first of all if
you think you're depressed you know see
a doctor and talk to them about
medication and also be healthy eating
right and exercise to make a huge
difference and finally if you're in the
cast of a late-night comedy show it
might help if they you know do more of
your sketches last week he opened up
about his experience being a target for
cyber bullies writing I've been getting
online bullied and in public by people
for nine months I've spoken about BPD
and being suicidal publicly only in the
hopes that it will bring awareness and
help kids like myself who don't want to
be on this
no matter how hard the internet or
anyone tries to make me kill myself I
won't I'm upset I even have to say this
oh my gosh now our thoughts and support
are with Pete if you or someone you know
needs help please call the National
Suicide Prevention lifeline and 1-800 to
73 talk
[Music]
you